[Music]
from the people who brought you crap get
on the screen oh why didn't you put a
minion warning on this thing geez
comes a film about what animals do when
their owners leave the house make
mediocre kids movies the secret life of
pets enjoy the exact same premises Toy
Story without all the toys or hard or
humor or story structure in this
disposable kids flick that will make you
hate Pixar for giving us all unrealistic
expectations when we watch a movie made
for six-year-olds there's supposed to be
dumb remember meet Katy max Duke Chloe
Sweet Pea Mel Norman buddy Tiberius
snowball Gidget ozo pops and a dozen
other characters who spread this thing
so thin you'll barely care about any of
them as a simple story about what pets
do when they're alone takes a hard left
in the car chases killer sewer animal
calls and psychedelic sausage factories
but hey it'll make you feel like a kid
again because you'll have no idea what's
happening or why
get ready to say hey I recognize that
voice
followed by hey why would they do this
as Louie CK Hannibal Buress and Jenny
slate sacrificed their indie cred to
make poop jokes with Kevin Hart oh just
ignore what just happened okay watch the
tiny comic shine is the equally tiny
snowball a revit who spends 90 minutes
yelling random Kevin Hart things whoa Oh
y'all call Vladek while setting the tone
for this movie's most defining feature
violence lots and lots of violence you
chose your side and now you're gonna
borrow oh my god they're animals all
right they're animals enjoy a movie
about every kind of pet with the balls
to say that dogs are dumb and loyal
while cats are total a hose I don't care
about you or your problems I'm gonna
have to ask you to get off my lawn gonna
cut you into string Bowl you up and then
bat you around for hours and birds are
so pointless most of them can't even
speak stop sweet pain not the name
that's wrong I just didn't think we
could say it out loud without pissing
off the weird cat people so gather of
the kids then leave the room for a
Looney tune stop slapstick adventure
that wastes it's fun premise waste this
New York City setting and wastes 90
minutes of your time more or less in
offensively in a film that falls
somewhere between Pixar's be material
and the movie that shall not be now get
up go to starring
story louis c.k nine modern family dog
kevin short unbar cable Kimmy Schmidt
the voice of the Sheep in Zootopia the
voice of Marla hey you're cheating on
Pixar and feline diabetes despicable
pets so did they really need to include
all the how do I say this cat buttholes
be sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers hey screen junkies still up for
some holiday pinching will we just
dropped for all new episodes of our
exclusive series with how it should have
ended after credits including Harry
Potter Creed and predator click on the
left to watch now and don't forget to
submit for fan fights you could earn a
free trip to Hollywood and appear as a
contestant on movie fights click the Box
on the right to learn more you can get
anything you want at Alice's Restaurant
I am vengeance I am the night
I am super Thunder Morphin bat ninja he
Joe I hate Mars bars members Star Wars
yeah I'm member roses are red violets
are blue I read all the comments just
not ones from you I ate your turkey on
Thanksgiving